now i think is a good time to add some
notation and techniques to our laplace
transform toolkit
so the first thing i want to introduce
is just it's just kind of a quick way of
doing something
and that is if i had the laplace
transform let's say i want to take the
laplace transform
of the second derivative
of y
well we've proved several videos ago
that if i wanted to take the laplace
transform
of the first derivative of y that is
equal to
s times the laplace transform
of y
minus y of zero
right and we use this property in the
last couple of videos to actually figure
out the laplace transform of the second
derivative
because if you just you know if you say
this is y prime this is the
anti-derivative of it then you can just
pattern match and you can say well the
last laplace transform of y prime prime
that's just equal to
s times the laplace transform
of y prime
minus
y prime
of zero right
the
this is the derivative of this just like
this is the derivative of this right
i'll draw a line here just so you don't
get confused laplace transform of y
prime prime is this thing and now we can
use this which we proved several videos
ago to resubstitute and get in terms of
the laplace transform of y
so we can expand this part
right the laplace transform of the
derivative of y that's just equal to
s times the laplace transform
of y
minus y of 0
and then we have the outside right we
have s
minus y prime of
zero
and then when you expand it all out and
we've done this before you get
s squared times the laplace transform
of y
minus s times y of zero
minus y prime
of zero now there's something
interesting to to note here and if if
you learn this it'll make it a lot
faster you won't have to go through all
this and risk making careless mistakes
when you have when you have scarce time
and paper on your test
just notice that when you take when you
take the laplace transform of the second
derivative what do we end up we end up
with s squared right this was the second
derivative we end up with s squared
times the laplace transform of y
minus s times y zero minus one times y
prime of zero so every term we started
with s squared and then every term we
lowered the degree of s1 and then
everything except the first term is a
negative sign
and then we started with the laplace
transform of y and then you could almost
view the laplace transform as a kind of
integral so we kind of take the
derivative so then you get y
and then you take the derivative again
you get y prime and of course every
other term is negative and these aren't
the actual functions these are those
functions evaluated at zero but that's a
good way to help you hopefully remember
how to do these and once you get this
the hang of it you can take the laplace
transform of any arbitrary function very
very quickly or any arbitrary derivative
so let's say we wanted to take the
laplace transform
of i don't know this should hit the
point home the fourth derivative of y
that four in parentheses means the
fourth derivative i could have drawn
four prime marks but either way so what
does this equal to if we use this
technique and substituted we were bound
to make some form of careless mistake or
other it would take us forever and it
would waste a lot of paper but now we
see the pattern and so
we can just say well the laplace
transform of this in terms of the
laplace transform of y right that's what
we want to get to is going to be
s to the fourth
s to the fourth times the laplace
transform
of y
now every other term is going to have a
minus in front of it
minus
lower the degree on the s
minus s to the third
and then you can kind of say let's take
the you know some form of derivative so
that you get y
of zero it's not a real derivative the
laplace transform really isn't the
antiderivative of y of zero but anyway i
think you get the idea and then we lower
the degree on s again minus s squared
take the derivative and of course these
aren't functions but we're taking we're
evaluating
the derivative of that function now at
zero so
y prime of zero
minus now we lower the degree one more
minus s
times this is an s
times
y
prime prime
of zero we have one more term lower the
degree on the s one more time then you
get s to the zero which is just one so
minus
and
one is the coefficient and then you have
y
the third derivative of y
let me scroll over a little bit the
third derivative of y evaluated at zero
so i think you see the pattern now and
this is a much faster way of evaluating
of evaluating the laplace transform of
an arbitrary derivative of y as opposed
to keep going through that pattern over
and over again
another thing i want to introduce you to
is just a notational savings
and it's just something that you'll see
so you might as well get used to it it
actually saves time over keep you know
keep writing this curly l in this
bracket if i the laplace transform
of y of t
i can write as and people tend to write
it as
what's going to be a function of s and
they what they use is they use a capital
y
to denote the function of s
and that well
it makes sense because normally when
we're when we're doing anti-derivatives
you just take you know when we take
we often when you learn the fundamental
theorem of calculus learned that the
integral
of f with respect to dx you know from 0
to
x is equal to
capital f of x so it's kind of borrowing
that notation because the this function
of s is kind of an integral of y of t
the the
laplace transform to some degree is a
kind of it's like a special type of
integral where you have a little
exponential function in there to mess
around with things a little bit
anyway i just want you to get used to
this notation when you see capital y of
s that's the same thing as the laplace
transform of y of t and you might also
see
see it this way
the laplace transform
of f of t
is equal to
capital f of s
and and the clue that tells you that
this isn't just the normal
anti-derivative is the fact that they're
using that s the as as the independent
variable because in general s represents
the frequency domain and if people were
to use s with just a general
anti-derivative people would get
confused et cetera et cetera
anyway i'm trying to think whether i
have time to teach you more fascinating
concepts of laplace transform well sure
i think we do so my next question for
you and now we'll teach you a couple
more properties and this will be helpful
in taking laplace transforms
what is the laplace transform
of e
to the a t
times f of t
fascinating well let's just go back to
our definition of the laplace transform
it is the integral from 0 to infinity
of e to the minus st
times whatever we have between the curly
brackets
so with the curly brackets we have e to
the a t
f of t
dt and now we can add these exponents
right we have a similar base so this is
equal to what this is equal to the
integral from 0
to infinity
and let's see i want to write it as i
could write minus s plus a but i'm going
to write it as minus
s minus a
t and you can expand this out right it
becomes minus s plus a which is exactly
what we have here
times f of t
f of t
dt now let me show you something
if i were to just take the laplace
transform of f of t
the laplace transform of just
f of t
that is equal to some function of s
right
it is equal to some function of s
whatever we essentially have right here
for s it becomes some function of that
so this is interesting this is some
function of s here all we did when to
get
to go from well actually let me rewrite
this laplace which is equal to
0 to infinity
e to the minus s
t
f d dt right the laplace transform of
just f of t is equal to this which is
some function of s right
well the laplace transform of e to the a
t
times f of t
it equals this and what's the difference
between this and this
what's the difference between the two
well it's not much here wherever i have
an s i have an s minus a here right
so if this is a function of s what's
this going to be it's going to be that
same function whatever the laplace
transform of f was is going to be that
same function but instead of s is going
to be a function
of s
minus a
and once again how did i get that well i
said the laplace transform of f is a
function of s
and it's equal to this
well if i just replaced an s with an s
minus a i get this which is a function
of s minus a which was the laplace
transform of e to the a t times f of t
maybe that's a little confusing let me
show you an example so if i let's just
take the laplace transform
the laplace transform of
cosine
of two t
we've shown is equal to
well i'll write the notation it's equal
to
some function of s and that function of
s is s over s squared plus 4. we've
shown that already
and so the laplace transform
of e to the i don't know
t
times cosine of 2t
is going to be equal to the same
function but instead of s is going to be
a function of s
minus a so s minus 3
which is equal to
s minus 3
over
s
minus 3
squared
plus
four
notice when you get when you just
multiply something by this e to the
three t and then or e to the a t you
take the laplace transform of it you
just it's the same thing as a laplace
transform of this function but
everywhere where you had an s you
replace it with an s minus this a
anyway i hope i didn't confuse you too
much with that last part i think my my
power adapter actually just went on i
hope the video keeps recording i'll see
you in the next one